Um, okay. So, a lot of you have been
here before, some of you are new. Uh,
this is AI that works, where me and Vibb
talk about AI that works. Uh, it's a
very, uh, straightforward title. Um, my
name is Dex. I'm the founder of a
company called Human Layer. We help
people build better, safer, more
interesting, more useful agents. Um, and
Vibb, I'll let you do your intro. Cool.
I'm Vibb. I'm Vibb. Um, I work on BAML
and if you don't know what BAML is,
check it out. It's an interesting way to
use LMS in a way that's kind of fun.
With that, yeah, today we're going to
talk about entities and entity
resolution and dduping and resolving.
And um I think we've got a pretty
interesting kind of like it's it's kind
of a toy use case, but I think it really
will demonstrates really well some of
the um kind of core ideas there and um
will be a fun thing that you can pick up
and we'll try to keep it simple enough
that you can pick it up and run with it.
Um this meeting is being put it in your
own put it in your own code and then um
we will push all the code that we write
today as well. All right. So what is
entity resolution? What is entity
duping? Um, and how are all these terms
kind of related? I think that's the
first thing I want to start with over
everything else. So, I'm going to screen
share. I'm going to talk about uh empty
resolution. I realized I need my mic or
my mouse for today.
All right. Well, he's getting that. Oh,
he's back.
All right. So really quickly, I think a
lot of people mix up entity resolution
to these smaller problems into a giant
problem and that makes the problem much
much harder. So I'm going to really
quickly clarify exactly what we're going
to go cover and what we're going to talk
about.
So step one is we always have entities.
So we have like some sort of name that
we want to extract or some class of
names that we want to pull out. So the
most common example that I think
everyone can relate to is let's say
company names. I have a database of
people that are registered that I know
about that are legal entities of
companies and I want to say that no
matter what someone says I want to pull
out that sort of data and there's
different ways that we can go about this
problem. So let's take a couple sample
names so we all can think about this. So
someone might write the word Xbox
someone might write the word MSFT when
talking about the stock price ticker.
Someone might write the word Microsoft.
um someone might misspell Microsoft
and we might even have other things like
um Microsoft Inc. uh or whatever they're
called. All of these kind of map to the
same entity as far as I'm concerned
assuming that I don't care about
subsidiaries. I'm going to make that
claim right now. And they all kind of
map to this entity that I have
specifically. This entity isn't just a
plain entity. I also often have some ID
attached to it in my database that is
very very specific.
And what I want to be able to do is
somehow get this information out. Now,
there's two different problems that
exist in here. And we're going to skip.
And there's one last problem that we
didn't mention, I guess. Uh, enriching.
Um, so in this case, we're dduping
entities. So no matter what everyone
says, we're going to spit out the same
ID. We're resolving them to the same
exact entity, and we're going to extract
this data out of it. So we want to
extract from whatever information the
model gives us this independent process.
Now there are a couple ways that we can
go do this. We can prompt our way to
trying to do this. We give it the LLM
all of the companies and we say only use
this list of companies. Yeah. What's the
what's the naive approach to this? I
guess like what does that look like?
Like what similar to like the
classification problem, right? Let's
write the let's write the function
signature because I think that helps.
Def. Yep.
D and we'll we'll assume we're going to
extract a single entity for now. We
might have multiple but we'll take that
out. Uh input will be a string and the
output will be an entity type. Um an
entity type
will have a name stir which doesn't
really matter and some ID that is like
some sort of database ID that does
matter. And the most naive way to do
this is my function will also take in a
uh list of entities.
And I ask super dumb. I just ask Alm to
pick one of these. So I can write
something like this. Pick best choice
equals ask lm input options. And I'm
certain many of us can write a prompt to
go do this. This isn't that interesting.
The next level of uh complexity that we
can add is we can say now if best choice
not in options for some sort of stir
match function
or some sort of match function that we
write return none
else
best return best choice. So now we've
done Go ahead. And this could even be a
place where you would incorporate some
of those um the stuff we talked about in
the eval episode of like having runtime
guards of like Okay, cool. We know for
sure that it has to be in this list. So
if it's not, we just kind of like add
more error context to it and ask the LM
to try again at least once. Yeah. So we
could exactly we could be like oh um we
could literally just do it like try
again. It's like we could put a thing
here. is like num tries
equals
uh int
equals like three by default.
Uh if
if num tries
less than uh greater than zero
return.
We just recursively call itself and you
should do recursion but for now
um so we could do this uh we could go
escalate to a human. We can do all these
things that we want to go do in here.
But there's a couple other reasons that
it might not exist. There are other
reasons that it might not exist such as
like our entities array itself might be
incomplete. Like imagine that in
Microsoft case, great. We can we can
scrape the S&P 500. We can get all the
top businesses that we know about and we
pass them into here. But in Microsoft's
case, we might actually run into an
issue where let's say someone's looking
for the company Human Layer. Human Layer
probably doesn't exist in most public
registries yet. And I say yet, it will
in about a year or two. Whoa, buddy.
We're on Crunch Base. That's true. Um,
but uh if you're on there, you might not
find the right entity because it's just
missing information. You might want to
have an option to enrich data.
So, you might want to actually consider
enriching your options array itself over
here and then updating your options
array for next time around. And the
options for enriching are kind of what
you said, Dexter. You could escalate to
a human to go enrich it. You can
escalate for another pipeline that's
completely independent that scrapes the
web and searches for everything along
that lays and builds a list of
candidates and then passes off to a
human or does it yourself.
Or you can always just sorry one more
thing
or you can just do the thing that we did
in this current code which says we will
do nothing and we'll just return none in
that scenario. So there's it's kind of
up to the caller to decide what to do if
it's none. Exactly. It's your choice how
much rigor you want to have on your
pipeline, how much automation you add in
this process. But the actual process of
entity extraction, as it turns out, like
this this method of doing this, I find
this to be a little bit easier than um
than even this goes along. And I think
actually the best way to show this is
code, not even whiteboarding. Uh because
it's surprisingly very very
straightforward. So let's just go ahead
into the AI that works repo. Um, cd
repos
get pull just in case
pull drease.
Okay, clear. Okay. Um ls maker
2025 06
uh entity extraction
let's see
cool uh uv init and then uv add baml-py
oops
uv
we run baml cli test sorry we do this
usually ahead of time, but Oh, it
all right. It's good. This demonstrates
how easy it is to do this. And while
he's doing that, Derrick, you had a
question?
Yeah, I was just gonna maybe if it if I
could take the liberty to add like a use
case in real world where I've done this
kind of with TF diff and Excel as human
in the loop when it didn't get above a
threshold match which now I can see
these identified pipelines being another
level. So I tried to take like a
deterministic approach with a threshold
first and then fall back to like this
type of thing. Anyway, long story short
was a Barnes & Noble Digital Nook. They
they had like so many uh contracts with
Adobe. And so they had a a database of
contracts of 10,000 contracts they had
that they some of them were were weren't
assigned to people. Some they were
paying and not using. And uh we did this
process to align all of the Adobe Adobe
systems, Adobe, you know, into basically
Adobe products and Adobe consulting and
literally took like it turned out there
were 40 kind of unique like contracts
under different things that weren't
visible and brought them all into those
two categories. So they had a total
aggregate view of their Adobe spend.
They found the ones that had no owner
and that they could actually save and
that like five or 10 minutes paid for
our project. Nice. Um so I just wanted
to mention this is like type of things
that you could use this and I could give
other examples. Uh yeah I think
resolving something to the same shared
ID is generally useful when things have
many many multitudes of inputs. It's a
very very general problem and I think
the problem that we're going to talk
about today is one that should be
obvious to everyone which is like
resumes. Obviously, if I have a Caner
database, how many of you use some ATS
system and you just want to search for
the person that works in my shop at
Amazon? Like people wrote like AWS or
something else that isn't really
relevant, but really I just want to
search for all employees of Amazon. I
know when we go and hire people, we
always look for people by candidate
references of different companies,
different backgrounds, different skill
sets. Like for example, I wrote CV
engineer, but I just want to look for
people that have computer vision
expertise. that's going to be hard to go
find unless I can do some sort of
resistant entity resolution. Like skills
tags are another example of where you
want to do entity resolution. You want
some level of entities that are well
known, well established, and highly
useful. And you also want to have
adaptability of that. For example, in
this case, Boundary ML should be its own
entity, but likely that a database won't
have that on day zero. So, I want to be
able to track and amend my entities
database while I go do this. And that
part is the part I think that makes this
problem so interesting and so
fascinating. It's not merely by
extracting.
It's about how do you build and maintain
an entity database that is changing ever
so often all all the time. And I think
that's the problem that we should dive
into today. Cool.
Well, let's look at this code. So in
this case, I have something really
really simple. I have a thing that is a
functional extract resume. It's going to
extract a resume from uh this place and
we're just going to have experiences.
But now I want to go do this. I'm going
to go add some um test cases really fast
just so I know because I know that this
is going to be a problem. I want this to
be Microsoft obviously. Um I'll put like
GCP.
Uh and hopefully we'll figure out what
it figures out on there. Um and I
specifically left ambig ambiguous
uh ambiguous uh so I know what it is. Um
and now let's go play around with this.
Obviously, if I go do this, it's not
going to work off the top of my off the
top of my head. If I just say like at
description get the real company name
legal
legals name.
Uh, let's run this.
And like it did some stuff. It did
Alphabet Inc., it did Microsoft. And
like if I spin it down to GPT4 mini, who
knows? Maybe this will work, maybe it
won't. It kind of did, but there's no
guarantee. I'm really relying on the
vibes of the LM to hope that I get this
correct. And I think that's the thing
that we should go up take upscale a
little bit. So let's just make this an
experience data model.
And I'm just going to focus on company
and title. I won't even add anything
else. Description.
I don't need this.
The legal
company name.
And this will kind of work
I think but it really didn't like Google
isn't actually a legal company name.
Neither is my shop. It's actually like
my shop inc or something else. So let's
make another object in here to help the
model really understand what we mean.
Name
as verbatim
batum from
content.
uh legal name
um
is subsidiary.
Let's just know if it's a subsidiary
really fast. Mhm. And let's run this.
Cool. Uh it pulled this out. This is for
viob resume. Let's run the other test
case now, the ambiguous one,
and see what it does. The ambiguous test
case, you remember, has boundary ML,
GCP, and Xbox. GCP legal name Xbox and
it it's really not understanding what I
want. So let's do the first thing and
just like beef up the model.
Uh really not understanding what I want
either. Um name I'm telling you man peak
peak working hours they make all the
models dumber. It's my new conspiracy
theory. Uh let's get rid of is
subsidiary and then let's ask legal
name. What I want to know is if
available
best guess at the legal name of the
company
and we might find that we actually it's
interesting right we immediately got
Microsoft Corporation Google LLC and
Boundary ML Inc. which is not the real
name. So now let's go over here. Company
type uh wellestablished well-known
uh startup because those are really the
two established companies that I might
have. So let's just go and establish
this. Yeah, because you kind of and
that's basically you're helping to
filter between like how likely is this
to be something that the model made up?
Because if the model doesn't pick well
known then it's more likely that it's
not in the training set basically right
or owning
exactly and now we're noticing it's
listing on Google cloud platform um and
then we can say we can add more uh
well let's add another one known
subsidiary which I think is good
over here if
If well known
of
the owning company. So let's read my
prompt really fast. What I have out here
I changed my data model. The name I
still want to be verbatim from the
content. Then I want it to tell me that
what company type I am. I'm either
wellknown a well-known subsidiary or a
startup. And then I want to tell me in
the legal name, I want it to actually
tell me if it's well-known, best guess
of the legal name of the company. If
it's a well-known subsidiary, best case
of the owning company. So I'm actually
being very deliberate with the actual
model itself. And I'm actually going to
make this an optional field because in
the case of a startup, I don't want to
spit out a legal name.
Skip if startup.
Okay. So this is almost like forcing a
very specific flavor of reasoning onto
the extraction process. Exactly. And you
can see now the model is actually like
kind of understanding what I want to do
a lot better.
Um and it's actually spinning out what I
want. Now this is only half the battle
because at this point I now have
something. Let's just see if GP4 mini
works really fast. Why not? Right. This
doesn't let you leverage your database
of named entities and it doesn't let you
evolve the database over time. Exactly.
And we can see that hey GCP uh a
well-known um
what's it called well-known subsidiary
is probably not working as well uh or
like uh like GCP isn't working as well
in G uh GP uh GP 40 because 40 Mini
still says Google Cloud Platform. Yeah,
but that's okay. We actually don't want
to worry about that too much because we
could spend forever prompting this or we
can add a multiaceted approach to go
solve this problem. Cool. So let's take
a look at what that approach would look
like.
So now what we're going to do is do
something like this.
Um
I'll put I'll put a real example here.
Um, I'll just take this example. As I
said,
also be interesting to see this with
like the actual raw text from like a
real resume rather than this little like
fake markdown thing. I will Yeah, I'll
do that in a second. Um, I just think
it's I like to use toy examples because
then we don't have to all digest all the
examples at first. Yeah, like resume
equals this. Cool. So now we have a
resume and what we're going to do now is
we're actually going to go access all
the experiences
for company in
for EXP
exp.
No, there's a company type. Oh, I have
to set up my UV environment.
U packetic.
This is a company type for company dot
uh let's say legal name. So I want to
first get the legal name. So I'm going
to do a couple of things um and be like
uh in uh extract companies in here. So
company
exp.
Okay. What I'm going to do over here is
first I'm going to go ahead and actually
get the actual type of the company.
match exp
type
case
uh startup I don't really care and I'll
just like print it out and I don't
really want to do anything
uh I don't actually know if I have to
break I might have to
okay
do nothing in fact I might even want to
do one more thing where I like
specifically will set the legal name of
the company explicitly to none
because I do not want in the case of a
startup, even if the LM hallucinates
something, I'm just going to ignore it.
It doesn't matter to me. It's like it's
garbage data. If it's a well-known
company, um I'm going to see if it has a
legal name.
Uh if it if it does if it doesn't have a
legal name and it's a well-known
company, I might figure out um to do ask
an LM
else. Now if I have to go do this now I
want to do the next thing which is
validate names
which I will do is like validate company
which I'll take in the exp company
itself and I want to go validate this
somehow.
Now what I will do over here is write a
validate function.
There you go. And the way I'll validate
this is I'll assume that I have a list
of companies def load companies.
Um, and what this will return is this
will return a list of tupils. Oops.
Of like name,
comma, like legal name
or like maybe I'll what I'll do is
actually something slightly different.
Sorry. legal name and then also return a
list of actual descriptions about that
company. So in the case of Go ahead. Are
we going to end up doing something
similar to what we did in the
classification where we kind of have a a
internal class that our program manages
and controls the view that is like what
the database sees versus what the LM
sees versus what the what the code sees.
Exactly. It's a very very similar
pattern but it's slightly different. In
the case of what I will be doing here is
I'll say like company valid equals load
companies
valid companies both this and then for
valid company invalid companies I'm
going to just see if the legal name
of this thing that I have over here
matches this. If the legal name is
coming in my database I am good. That
doesn't Okay. So, so it's almost like a
a group by where you have the where you
have like an index from legal name to
all of the known company names
basically. Exactly. Exactly. And in the
case of me not finding some valid
company that I like, then what I will do
after this is now I need to to do ask an
LLM
to update
uh ask an LLM to
uh update the company to find. Yeah, you
have a lot of ask LLMs in here and I'm
not they seem to be different things in
different parts of the workflow. Yeah.
So, I'm just writing to-do comments
here. But what I want to do is I'm just
going to load all the companies from my
database and if I find if I find one it
matches the legal names that I am aware
of in my database, I'm good. If I'm
unable to find one, then what I want to
do is I want to ask the LM. So in this
case, it's been out Google Cloud
Platform. So I literally just dump the
valid companies into my uh LLM and ask
them to pick one. I basically turn this
problem into a classification problem.
Why not just dump the list of valid
companies in any like at the start in
the original prompt? Well, a couple of
reasons for that and I think that's a
really really good question. Well, one
of them is I can get a good bang for my
buck without doing that. Like I see you
use the cheap model with a small prompt
and like a lot of times it will just get
it right. Exactly. And then if you're if
you're any reasonably sized company,
your ATS of legal companies that you're
going to be hiring from is going to be
massive.
Just has to be by definition. So
instead, okay, so you're you're just
like pre-optimizing this basically,
right? like our our normal advice is
like use the biggest model and the
biggest prompt and the most powerful
thing first and then break it down when
it becomes a performance bottleneck. But
in this case, you're just saying like
I'm going to actually start with a
smaller tighter tighter model and then
zoom back out to a bigger model if I
don't find something that kind of
matches my expectations. Yes. And then
one last caveat is that like I can't
actually put together my actual um I
can't fit all the companies I know about
into the prompt. I know that from the
get. I see. Yeah. Right. Like we all
know that from the very beginning. We
can't do that. Like for this problem of
extracting resumes. It's not possible
for the PDF contract problem. It's not
possible to put all the contracts into
most problem that have an entity
resolution problem can't do this on day
one. You can't just put it all in a
prompt. That's actually a much better
answer. Yeah. So like it it kind of it
would be wasteful for me to go even
write the base prompt because it it I
know up front by definition of the
problem, I can't do it. Cool. And so I
imagine there's some stage where we kind
of like if we if we do want to push them
in, we would narrow down the set that we
pass into the LM. Exactly. And that's
literally what we do over here. We do
the same thing we did in the
classification problem. This is
basically this is a classification
problem.
Cool.
Okay. At this point, because all I'm
doing is I'm taking the legal name of
the company like Google Cloud Platform
and trying to classify it against the
known companies and we all know how to
do classification problems. There's many
different approaches. One example is we
just dump all the companies into there.
Another example is we go ahead
and go do the whole thing. So it's
really up to us how we go about this
problem. But this basically becomes a
classification problem at this point.
And in the case, the only difference is
now I'm allowed to return other or like
no company found.
And if I find no company found, then I
have a choice of what I do at this
point. This Okay. So, we're actually
going to kind of like skip over that
classification part and just zoom out
and look at the B bigger broader
pipeline. Right. Exactly. Because
there's no point in rewriting that
process again. Um I think if someone is
interested they can go look at the
classification video we did a couple
weeks back and just know we will put a
we'll put a link to that in the uh in
the show notes. Yeah. Uh but like once
you do the classification refer
to video. Um
once you do that then you're basically
able to go move on. Now you have a valid
company. Now the problem is this won't
always return a valid company. Sometimes
it'll return something not found. So we
want to go update this and make this a
little bit better for ourselves. So
sometimes we'll return this otherwise
we'll return none for now. Very
simplistic.
Now what we want to do over here is I
need to enumerate this.
If uh result equals this, if result is
none,
if the result is none, then I kind of
want to val invalidate the company and
mark it as such.
Otherwise, I'm okay leaving it as that.
I kind of want to say this legal name is
not valid.
So even because the legal name is what
you're going to use to map that's like
you're using that as a proxy to the
database ID basically. Exactly. Exactly.
I'm using this as a database ID. So if
I'm unable to find a valid company for
this legal name, I'm going to go and
like just not care about it. If I am
able to find a valid legal name, then
I'll go do this. And in this
classification problem, what I do is
like I'd call an LLM. If it found a
valid legal name, I would just change
the legal name of the object that I have
and return it back. Cool. Cool. So now I
have this. I'm able to go do this. Now
there's a couple scenarios in here that
all that all fail. Same with the legal
name over here. This is also like
classified. So like let me just write a
function really fast. Class pick
potential
uh name company
uh uh content
stir and what this will return is like a
stir or none passed.
So what is the content that got that
gets passed in there? Exactly. So what I
would do is I'd pass into here potential
company.name.leal
name. So I pass in the legal name of the
company and ask it that if
return
company.leal name equal potential
company uh return company. So this is
what I I think this I keep getting
tripped up by the tupils. Are you down
to put a couple like actual examples in
there instead of like the names of the
columns? That's a good idea. Microsoft
Corporation,
uh, Xbox,
uh, Xbox, Azure,
um, MSFT,
and maybe there should be a dictionary.
Maybe that'll be easier.
Sure. Uh, there we go. Cool. Uh, Google
does not own GitHub.
Um, this is like one example of
companies. Sorry about that. Good call
on that. Um
it items
valid company. Um cool.
There we go. Cool. All right. So now
what I would do is I just pass in legal
name. I pick the uh potential company.
And what I can do over here is like or
legal name and how many and I just
return this. So now I'm doing something
very very simple, very simple, which is
I just see if any of the aliases match
the content and if they do then I'll
return the legal name. This could be an
LM function but I'm choosing to use a
very basic heristic here instead.
Does that make sense Dexter? Yeah. So so
this content is really like a like
company name.
Yeah. Which one? This one. So I mean we
use content in the main function and in
that case content is like the source of
the resume. I just I don't want to mix
up those we're going to do something
over here. So in this scenario where the
legal name wasn't provided for a company
then we're going to do this potential
but it's not the full resume it's the
company.name.
Exactly. So if the legal name is none
I'm going to pick a potential company by
passing in the legal name. So I guess my
point was like in pick potential company
should that v variable be called company
name? Uh
it's not always going to be the company
name because in different places I'm
passing different things in the valid
where I have a valid company. I'm going
to pass in the legal name. In the case
of where the legal name was not filled
out by the LLM, I'm going to pass in the
actual name of the company verbatim from
the resume.
Okay? Using different things to go do
this. And you can imagine that I pass in
like different piece of content. I might
pass in the whole experience block into
here. It's really up to me as a
developer to decide what I want to go
do.
But the goal of this function is to say
given some string, tell me all the
relevant pieces of content that might
match that company. And if I have it,
then I update my company name into here.
Now, the nice thing that I'm able to do
about all this is I'm also invalidating
names that come back to me from the LM.
If the LM gives me a name, I'm
invalidating it if it's not valid.
In addition to that, I also am going to
go ahead and do the same thing with
subsidiaries. I'll do the exact same
thing. So, I'll just like put this over
here.
Oh, I can't do that in Python. I didn't
know that. Okay.
You might be able to use an or
something.
Um Oh, maybe. Oh, I can. Nice.
I didn't know that. Cool. Match is
pretty freaking cool. Um, so now I can
actually go do this and I can handle the
scenario really nicely. Now I can build
a Now that I've done this, I basically
have a pipeline that is able to go ahead
and validate all sorts of things in
here. Let's go run this really fast.
Um, I'm actually going to make the
problem a little bit simpler and change
what model I used to be a very very bad
model.
Lama
latest.
I don't know if this will work, but it
might.
Oh, lsv
run python-fellow.
Mhm. There we go. So, I'm going to go
run this with an oama model really fast
and see what happens.
My old might not be out.
Oops.
Uh, there we go. Okay, there you go.
Something happens. So, the model Oh, I
forgot to print out stuff. That's funny.
Um,
let's go ahead and go print this out.
print.
There you go. That's what I wanted.
And I'm also going to print out the
response ahead of time.
Uh before and then after enriching.
after. Okay. Um and then BMA log equals
Oh.
Oh, this can't actually happen. That's
cool. Python yells at me. Um
so now we can see what happens before.
So before we have boundary ML null um
the Google cloud platform subsidiary of
Alphabet and then this thing did
actually not do this.
I might have to debug this a little bit
really fast.
Um this thing did not get enriched. Uh
let's see what happened.
Well-known subsidiary should have gone
into here. Expco company name. Uh let me
print this out.
You could just tell cursor agent to add
a bunch of print statements. That's
probably true. Add some debug print
statements.
Okay. Well, it does this.
Did it do it? Command ki.
This is the only problem with AI
generate code. It takes a while to
write.
Let's just go for it. Beautiful.
We're gonna have a lot of print
statements.
Um, have you ever used the cursor
debugger that lets you like step through
Python code? No, I haven't.
It's uh sometimes pretty good.
Uh, company type of startup. Did I make
something silly and not actually go
through every company?
Oh, I see. I didn't know Python this
break actually breaks out of the loop.
Out of the loop. Yeah. Yeah. I don't
think you want that. Okay, let's get rid
of more debug statements.
I want to go run this.
So now when we're able to go do this in
theory, um
this should
null out the actual legal name of the
GCP because it didn't actually work.
Okay, so this is just detecting which
ones can you accurately extract. This is
and then after that you could do another
pass to go try to ask an LLM to better
pick or do a lookup or do a rag against
the list or something like that.
Exactly. And now we can actually go
further and say if the result is none
what I can say is like
other names other names equals
pick potential uh sorry let's go to
validate company what I can say here's
if this is none what I also want to do
is another option uh from name equals
pick
and then I just return this. So, if I if
the actual legal name doesn't find it,
then I'll also try from the original
name that I got from the LLM when I'm
validating a company and we'll see what
this does.
So, the goal here is to say that there
are many ways that I could enrich it.
You can see right over here I was able
to enrich it to Google now
because what I said was oh even if the
LLM doesn't initially get a good legal
name which it did not. It got Google
Cloud Platform.
What I will do is I will go ahead and
try and find a good match. If I am
unable to find a good match from the
legal name I'll try the original name in
my database and see if I can go find it.
So you see we're going to go check does
the original name match one of the
aliases. space. Exactly. Match one of
the aliases. And this is again the most
simplistic algorithm that I could
implement here. I could do something
more sophisticated here such as calling
an LLM, asking another model to go save
things um or go do something. But now
this is still only half of the battle.
I'm still not done yet because we have
Boundary ML. Boundary ML is clearly not
going to be found in my database. So
what I need to do is I almost need to
build a totally separate workflow to
solve for that problem. And the best way
Yeah. And you could you could almost do
something aentic. I I I want to hear
what you were going to say, but I was
like you can almost do something aentic
here where it's like there's a LLM is
picking a tool that is like actually the
next step is to update our list of
companies because of some input or some
human input or whatever it is. Yeah, I
may not even need uh like really I might
just know that hey if it's a startup I
always need to do an agentic workflow
and I might want to maintain my list of
startups separately than my list of well
well-known companies or even mark these
as startups versus well-known companies.
So then what I could do now is like
build a database pipeline that says as
soon as I save a data into there, I push
something to an SQSQ that says go look
up information about Boundary ML and
here's database IDs that could be
impacted by Boundary ML. So if you find
a company called Boundary ML in the
cloud somewhere. So let's let's go back
to our whiteboard.
Uh where do they go? So now the next
step now that we have this pipeline
where we're pretty good about legally
known companies that we have in our
database. Now we have a separate thing.
Now what we're going to do is we're
going to create an AWS SQSQ that's going
to do a couple of things. It's going to
submit a job that says look for
info on
boundary ML. Also, by the way, the the
row ID that I just inserted is equal to
like uh like 50 uh 51.
And then So, your goal is basically
you're going to you're going to put in
what you extracted and then you're going
to say like, "Hey, we need to get a
legal name for this company." Exactly.
So, I'm going to give it I'm going to
give it give it the information I
extracted. I might even give it the raw
resume. Something else that I might want
to give it just to give it more context
on it. I might want to give it the full
resume, the original text or whatever I
have. But specifically, I'm going to
tell it I care about
I care about this company Boundary ML in
this resume. So now I can build a
pipeline whose job it is to first say
give me everything
every clue from the resume
about boundary ML.
Whoops.
And this becomes again a very simple
prompt that we can go do. Now I can use
web search or some other tool that I
want
uh to go find all the relevant
information. Then I can build a whole Go
ahead. Okay. So you would use those
clues you extracted from the resume to
build good web searches. Basically it's
like basically like if you didn't know
Boundary ML was an AI dev tools company.
Maybe you could figure that out from the
resume and then you would look search
for BAML AI instead of searching just
BAML and getting a bunch of things about
Bank of America. Exactly. or I might
have the location of the person and
where they live on or go do something
like that. I might find all sorts of
clues that might give me information
about that. Then you can make a bunch of
search queries, build a web search
pipeline and at some point this thing
will end. It'll put together a proposal
or it'll put together no proposal. It's
really up to you.
And now now that we have a proposal, we
have our list of databases. This becomes
an entry into there with a status of
proposed instead of committed.
And it is some other agent's job
to migrate us from proposed to
committed.
Now I see and that might be human input.
That might be more searches against the
database. You you decide the logic for
what lets you commit a new entity to the
database. Exactly. Uh information.
Right. If you're if you're doing this
for tax information, you want to
probably have a human in the loop. If
you're doing this for like resume ATS
information, it's just like small
enrichment for like making searches
better. Automate that sucker. It doesn't
matter. You might even want to go
straight to committed in that scenario.
It's up to you, right? I mean, it's also
like you there's two kinds of human in
the loop, right? There's human the loop
like do not commit this until someone
has reviewed it and then there's like
commit it and then anyone has the
ability to come back later and edit it
and update it. Right. Exactly. Exactly.
And we can just email our Slack channel
saying we added a new company. Go review
it pre uh whenever you have time. Yeah.
That async or batch human in the loop.
Exactly. And all of this whole thing
just becomes like a workflow that we've
built out. And now we have this other
last piece of information which is row
ID 51. Once it becomes committed, what I
need to do is I need to go to the other
database where I've stored this
information and then right because you
have two tables. You have tables of like
your abstractions, your extractions that
are like in progress or pending and then
you have the lookup table of all the
companies you know. Exactly.
And now update row 51 for boundary.
That's it. Once that is committed
and now we've actually built a pipeline
in a fully automated way or as automated
as this process is for proposed to
committed that can go find information
do web search and then go figure this
out.
Um before we go into the next part of it
any questions from anyone,
you can type in the chat or raise your
hand uh and come on.
I guess my question is like is there a
zooming out here bigger? Like is there
like what what what else is here?
Honestly, this is it. I've seen this
work a couple of places for different
couple of different companies. This
works for all sorts of processes. So
like another process that doesn't sound
the same but is exactly the same is
topic clustering.
So if you think about what topic
clustering is, let's say I want to have
like the most semantic mill, let's say
I'm building like a giant news media
company and I want to know what topics
are sensational in the world that I
should talk about right now. That's
basically the same pipeline. I have a
bunch of data because a topic is an
entity with like an official thing.
Exactly. What if I was making a tool to
like label all my Gmails for me? It's
same thing. I want to go do the same
thing. Um, and go do that. So, you don't
have to really think about any of those
concept because those labels are
entities and you want to you don't want
to make new labels all the time. You
want to resolve them to the same labels
whenever possible.
We got a question. Can Sorry. Go ahead.
Uh, and you can also do interesting
things with like not just labels but
also with um hierarchal labels. So you
can have like topics that are like
saying like we want to go up down up
down and you can go figure that out
uh along the way. So it's like do I want
the higher level category or the lower
level category? It's up to me and all of
that is almost the same problem. So in
the case like news media, I might want
to say like have global news and have
like Britain news or like US news and
those could be hierarchal design or
where I look for global news first and
then I find the subcategories around it
that are around like environmental stuff
or um
uh environmental stuff or like financial
news under global news or I can go
straight to financial news or global
news or uh financial stuff or
environmental notes along the way. Yeah,
the the multi- multi-entity grouping is
kind of tricky where something could
have multiple different categories and
like there's it's one of n instead of
exactly one company, then you just
return an array
and it's the same. And then you can run
through the same validation checks on
each thing in the array. Exactly. If you
if we're doing multilel thing, it's
actually really easy. All we do is let's
go do this really fast. I'm going to
turn on my Python type checker so we can
see how we actually catch these bugs.
Uh
um oh
let's add this in here. Sorry, static
analysis is very important to me. Um
so now that we go down here, let's go
ahead and like add this in our way. So
what what do I do over here? Well, maybe
there are multiple legal names that make
sense. So let's make this an array.
Let's pretend you worked at Palunteer
and you consulted for six companies but
it was one experience. Exactly.
Now what I have to do here is this will
return instead of a string. I mean this
can still return a string because this
is just like for content.
Uh legal name company.leal name.
We have a bunch of questions stacking up
by the way. Um sorry. No, you're good.
You're good. I didn't want to interrupt
you. Um
so uh I just I just want to do if you're
uh if you're let me do this one all we
have to do here is now we just make this
a for loop
and we have to do the same kind of code
wrapping to make this a for loop and
then we might want to resolve the same
if the for loop for some reason dumped
out like GCP G Google Cloud Platform we
want to resolve them both to one entry
called Google.
That's the only other you have to Oh,
and then you end up flattening the the
list. Exactly. It doesn't flatten the
list. Exactly. That's all that. Um,
cool.
Um, cool. Uh, um, can BAML use lower
level models like BERT or Alberta? Um,
right now we have just LM support, but
uh, you can if you wrap BERT or Alberta
around an LM API, uh, which I don't
think you can because they're just
embedding models really then, uh, for
now. But eventually, yeah. Yeah,
Michaela has a really cool example of
like if if the Baml run didn't didn't
return return like null for one of the
fields, they would go do a web search
with Tavali and then just pass that
context in. That's it sounds like they
they naturally discovered the same
process we just discovered today, which
is like if you got an empty field, which
is in this case got this data out of
here, you just run web search and do the
same thing again. That's kind of cool.
Yep. Um okay, when does the database
pipeline get triggered? Right after the
ML pipeline or was that from one of the
BAML functions? Oh, the database
pipeline would get triggered right over
here. So, what I can do now is I can say
like uh at the very end of the code.
Let's actually write that out. Yeah.
It's like Yeah, exactly. It's like you
you exit the loop, you've done all the
repairs you can, then you find the ones
that didn't get satisfied and you go
kick off jobs, right? Exactly. Is none,
then I just kick off a job.
Is none.
print uh kick
off AWS uh kick off job to find better
match.
So now I can go do this
and this is when I would go do this at
the very very end of this. Cool.
Um propose to committed is a bit vague.
You're updating data in a database in
prod for the company info search
results, but AI could commit on wrongful
information. Yeah. So, that's what we
talked about is like you need to uh look
at your risk and and your use case and
you may want to have kind of human in
the loop or you may want to have it push
it to like a stage database that gets
reviewed regularly and it gets queried.
Exactly. You can view your SQL table for
this company information table to look
something like this. Like you have like
a table called like company uh name
company uh uh like ID, company
attributes, like other keywords or
something that you might want to have
about it. Keyword you could have a I
guess like you could have a flag that
like whether it was human reviewed or
like how how hard committed it was,
right? And then you'd basically have
like company.status
company. status and status would be one
of like uh like uh proposed
uh ready.
Yeah. And you could even store the like
human comment or whatever it is. And you
could actually asynchronously go through
with an LM and try to repair this. Like
if a human said, "No, that's wrong."
Like go search for this that you could
you could kick off new jobs periodically
based on that. It's really important
that your data model represent the
complexity of your problem. So if you
need multiple drafts of a company before
you can get to a good resolution, you
need a data model that can go do that
and this is independent of an LLM. Like
this is even like if in Wikipedia for
example, they keep track of every edit
that every human makes so they can roll
them back really easily. That's what we
do with git. You just need to find the
right data model that represents the
complexity of your task. So in this
case, I did something very very basic
where I only have two booleans proposed
and ready. And I can make a web UI that
literally shows everyone on my at my
company internal dashboards a view of
these tables and people can manually
promote promote promote. And I can have
like a last updated column on top of
here is like um
last updated
that I sort by. So in the UI, people can
go see this and I can have information
about who the last person that updated
was or I can do what Dexter says and
keep a full edit log of the entire edit
history of that row and go make that
possible as well. It's up to me as the
developer of this application to decide
the requirements for this task. And this
is what we always say is it's it's
mostly engineering. If you can do the
software engineering behind this, you
can build the tool that fits your
problem and it's going to work a lot
better than one of these like
one-sizefits-all just like rag against a
thing and push it in and hope it works.
Yes. Does that answer your question?
Sure. Yes. Very cool. Uh I I really like
Sean's question. I was wondering if
you'd be down to come off mute and kind
of clarify a little bit more what you're
thinking about.
Um how do I think about performances of
large numbers of these matches? I guess
for if you're going to classify emails,
you could have 10,000 plus calls. Yeah.
Can you hear me? Okay. Yep. I'm actually
on the the train at the moment. So the
um yeah, there's that N plus1 thing. If
I have lots of emails, I want to, you
know, maybe I would think about batching
them. Um, or training
smaller models on my custom task, you
know, would be how I'd want to do it in
production potentially if I have lots of
similarly structured documents. So just
kind of curious your general philosophy
on using LMS in
your BAML framework and like am I just
kind of being old school and worrying
about that or just like just do the API
calls and and move on or should I be
thinking about something else here?
Yeah. Um well just as uh just as I think
we say a lot of times like this stuff is
pretty much just functions. So in this
case we have like a type signature. The
thing that implements this type
signature could be a really really
complicated model like 04 that we toss
at it. It could be GVD26, who knows? Um,
it could be a very tiny model that we've
custom trained to actually take a
specific content and then spit out the
actual company that we have trained on.
It can only output valid companies,
nothing else. It could be a really
really cheap heristic like the one I
wrote here that just matches on aliases.
So that becomes your prerogative. But
the most important thing is you just
need to collect data on what makes this
function really good. What makes this
type signature perform accurately.
So once you have large scales of
problems like and there's different ways
when you use the word performance. If
you're thinking about speed and cost and
latency
then yeah the answer is try not to use
an LLM right a really dumb heristic. Now
the problem is this heristic might not
balance very well for accuracy. So you
might need to use a bigger model. So
then you try a GPD, try like the 54
models like I was trying right now. And
if that doesn't work, then bump it up to
04 because so you can just ship the prod
and not have to write 5,000 lines of
code trying to optimize your model away.
And then collect data, use that data to
go train a tiny model, eval it against
your system by having a benchmark
because this system can be benchmarked
with an F1 score. So we can get a
numerical benchmark on this and then
just run that in a loop until you have a
type signature that meets the
constraints of your problem. But it's
really about thinking of it as type
signatures and once you think of it that
way then you choose what part of the
system you want to optimize as a
developer.
Does that answer the question? Yeah, I
love that. Um
very compelling part of the whole stack.
The uh the kind of last little follow up
is
my natural language.
Uh you're going to have to type that
out. Your audio is cutting out.
Step and then linking step. and you're
kind of doing it as a oneshot
sort of thing here.
Okay, I'll let him type it out while he
goes and that's it. Um, Dexter, is that
kind of how you think about optimization
as well?
Um,
yeah, I mean I think that tracks I mean
I'm still always all about this like
use the it's like what we did on the the
policy to props episode, right? It's
like take a subset, work through,
iterate on a small subset of a hundred
and then move up to a thousand and
understand the performance and like at
the end of the day, yes, if you want AI
to do the work, then like you're going
to have to spend the tokens to go do the
work on all the things, but like iterate
and get it tight on a small subset,
figure out learn what you can do with
smaller models before you like 10x the
number of records you're you're
processing on each run. Yeah, I agree. I
agree. I think that's a general
philosophy as well. Um, while we wait
for Sean's question, um, if anyone else
has more questions, feel free to type
them out in the chat. I'm going to show
you how to do some of the enrichment
tasks that we had like handwaved away if
that's useful. Function, uh, extract
uh, company clues
uh,
resume string uh, content uh, company
target company string. Okay. Um, given
this resume, tell me all the clues that
may help
me find information
about the company, target company.
Yeah. Or you could even just have it
output like queries for web search. So,
I will do that in a second, but I'm
going to go break this up. Um, so I'm
going to go run this in a very very
basic format
and like let's go do this
company clues
resume target company
uh boundary ML and what's interesting
about this is because I know that
extract company clues will only ever be
run on like large smaller companies I
build my test cases like that
accordingly as well. I don't actually
build my test case. I have Google. I
don't care because the input to this
function is guaranteed by my software
layer by the API definition of I have of
how I'm using this function that the
scope is only ever going to be unknown
companies. Now, that scope can change
like in regular software. Your function
can suddenly be used for concepts
they're not used to. And you just have
to keep that in mind. So, you might want
to drop a comment to let people know.
But let's go run this and see what it
does. Yep.
Um,
so it's giving me a bunch of clues. Uh,
this is not very good. U, let's go do
this. Uh, and go do this here. Class
clues,
uh, clues string array. Uh, good
searches. Good.
Google searches
string array. We'll change the data type
here to be a little bit better.
And I'm doing this in one shot.
And that's kind of interesting over
here. So now it's like
and it's interesting. It actually says,
oh, it might Boundary ML might be doing
computer vision stuff. It might be C++
and Rust might be parts of Boundary ML
stack. And now you can it actually gives
me pretty good
information about how to go find this.
What is your target company? Okay, so
it's it's still asking about the other
things. Interesting. Well, it might
because that might still be a good
search in terms of what it is. So, let's
make this better because I think you're
getting ambiguity on here. class search
uh like uh priority
I may
based on
which queries I should run first.
Oh cool. And then you can do like a
group buy and run them in in batches.
Exactly. Then I just run all my queries
that are high first
and like this is probably a good query
by Gupta foundry founder of mail that'll
probably get you to the legal name of
our company. Um found it and it's just
like helping you go do this and like I
would go just build a now we can imagine
how to build a pipeline off of you can
go iterate on that prompt and test this
and be like oh hey you're a expert
researcher whatever whatever prompt
tricks you want to use. Exactly. Uh and
then you can toss web search at it. You
can do whatever you want and you can
find information about this. Uh, tell me
clues that may help me find information.
Specifically,
I want to find the legal
name
of the company.
And I can like prompt my way through
this and just see what it does.
And now you can see the that the queries
got a lot better. And it's actually
really funny what the queries are doing.
It's actually giving me like search
queries of like who is patterns and like
actually really restricting this to this
and it's like looking for my name in
like quotes because it knows Google will
search for this specifically.
Oh man, I uh I almost want to give you
my Exa API key and have you run some of
these. I Yeah, so this is basically what
we would end up building. We'd go build
this out, then we'd actually go build
the search part of it and then we'd pull
the data out. We build an agent to
evaluate the results of the web search
to see if we have we basically write a
function that says extract legal name
function extract legal name from like
content uh and like search results.
Exactly. And just pull that out and then
I'd go do this
and I just go do this over and over
again until I have a good legal name.
Cool. And you could have it output like
six and then have a model do the judge
thing and pick one or two or three of
the best ones and then send three of
them to a human in Slack and be like
pick which one is the best and kind of
all that kind of stuff. Exactly. All
this basically just becomes software.
That's the point because all we're doing
is we're just designing like API
contracts that have some guaranteed data
model and now we know how to go deal
with this data model in one way. And
like for example like you naturally
being like a systems engineer you went
to being like oh I'll just run all the
high ones in batch parallel. Someone
might not do that. They may do
everything sequentially. They may write
all of them in parallel. It doesn't
matter. It's up to you as an engineer to
decide the trade-offs that you want to
make and the amount of system resources
you want to spend to find the answer.
Um, let's take Sean's question really
fast. Um, normally I do entity linking
as a two-step process, uh, with an
entity reference as a span and then a
link, but then I realized it's more of a
comment than a question. Um, yeah. So, I
see what you're saying. Cool. Yeah, the
span is kind of the only problem that
I've seen with the span is sometimes the
model if you like use URLs, we discussed
this last time in our prompt hacking
thing, a model is just less likely to
actually dump out a URL correctly. So, I
would just recommend swapping out the
URL with some like with some indexed ID.
So instead of having the model dump out
like
https
google.com like this
oops like this query is just going to be
way worse than having the model spit out
like um Google search idx0
like there's just way less tokens and
way way fewer things will go wrong
especially once the URLs have like
something like like ref equals like like
once you get to these things where
things aren't really mattering, your
tokens get completely screwed and hard
to go extract. So you want to be really
careful about what strings you have the
model actually spit out and you want to
reduce the noise or like entropy of
those strings to be as stable as
possible.
Um, and we discussed that last week. We
had a really fun time discussing all
sorts of techniques.
Are you on team beef up models as you
can as you dev or team weaken down
models as you dev? Um, personally I'm on
team of use the best model possible
initially cuz shipping your product is
way more important than um than cost in
the very beginning unless you know for
sure you have cost constraints. I
personally use the maximum amount of
resources that I can for a given project
without optimization in the very
beginning. Dex, what about you?
I like to use big models first and then
pair it down. Um, it depends on the
question. It's the same thing with
developing agents, too. Like the
12-factor agent stuff is all about like,
hey, let's get right in the weeds and
make things really, really good and
engineer everything. Like,
if you can just give a model 10 tools in
a prompt and it can get it right for
every single use case that you care
about, then do that. And then when you
find the things it can't get right,
that's when you start decomposing and
engineering. Exactly. Or like in our
case today, we knew for sure that it's
impossible for us to dump all the legal
companies into the problem. So, we're
not going to waste our time doing that
because it's it's it's it's not in the
constraints of our problem. So, we'll
start with the minimount of work that we
can. But, you you still need to know
where the walls of the box are and know
like, oh, yeah, I'll I'll never no
matter how good the no matter how big
the model is, this is just never going
to yield good results. So, we're going
to skip trying to do that. But, you'll
notice that I did not write an LLM
prompt for validate company, pick
potential company. I just did the dumb
thing where I just use aliases.
And it might work to be completely
honest. A lot of resumes probably use
like one of 50 words to mention a
company. I may not need an LM for this,
but I might want to use an LM anyway uh
because it's faster. I think one of our
engineers said a really really funny
thing um recently where they mentioned
that we don't actually want to do like a
standard library like languages might
not need a standard library anymore
because technically everything can be an
LLM function. Uh, actually I'll show his
expose.
Um, and I think that was better Antonio
because I thought this was very very
funny.
Uh, he talked about how when you're
actually doing a
uh you could technically do URL encoding
using an LLM instead of actually using
string interpolation and format strings.
And this becomes really interesting
behavior in the future as we as
developers can go out. And right now
this looks extremely silly because we
all know how to do URL encoding uh with
just like string interpolation. But this
might not be as crazy as it sounds
anymore like 5 years from now. Just like
Slack using 70 gigs of RAM would have
been insane 10 years ago, 20 years ago.
And now it's like it's okay. Every
laptop's got enough. We just go spend
the RAM. It might be true for compute as
well.
I love it. Um, anything else before we
close out?
Going once, going twice.
All right. Well, today we covered entity
extraction. Um, thank you guys for
joining us. Next week I think is going
to be really fun. Dex, do you want to
give them a preview of what we're
talking about? Yeah, so I dropped the
link in there. Um, so we do a lot of
work on this show. Um, but we also do a
lot of riffing. And our favorite thing
is to get on and talk with you about
your real problems. And the things that
we don't like doing as much is
downloading videos and creating
transcripts and writing up notes and
things like that. And so we want to
we're going to get a bunch of we're
going to get all the boring stuff set up
ahead of time, but we want to walk
through kind of building live a AI
content pipeline where you can take a
video like this, whether it's sessions
uh that we're doing, whether it's a
video you find online, whether it's a
meeting you have with the customer,
whatever it is, like take recorded
content and turn it into a content
pipeline of like a small blog post, uh
uploading the events in GitHub, pulling
out the transcript, um and kind of just
like doing as as much as we can do get
done in an hour of like how we run the
show in the background and how we use AI
to kind of make it better and how we
apply the we come here and talk about
all these like toy problems. So, next
week we're going to solve a real
problem.
Cool. We're going to be fun.
I have a quick question if you if you
don't mind if you have just a few
seconds. Um the the